today I had the privilege of meeting a  bunch of you in my dad's store in Jersey  for four hours  pictures selfies questions hugs  I just wanted to say Instagram and Tick  Tock and all of social media  I'm just so grateful for all of you just  appreciate the kind words and the warm  energy  you know it's really real like what you  put out is what you get in Normandy of  Love Today  just really affirms that like  I'm trying to put out as much love and  practical  advice and  mindset perspective advice and  opportunities I see advice and  it's not even advice it's just  opinions and hot takes and observations  and  just give me a lot of love back so I  love all of you thank you have the best  holidays can't wait to see more of you